[Musique]
salut Nathan non
ne vous avisez pas de laisser ce
rapisser à nouveau dans mon aller
c'était forcément l'un de vous
[Musique]
passez-moi la clé bonjour bonjour
comment tu t'appelles
excusez-moi je n'ai pas pu venir avant
j'ai des nouveaux voisins j'ai fait un
petit plat pour vous d'accord au revoir
vous êtes toujours aussi antipathique je
ne suis pas motivé
au cœur
[Musique]
vous pourriez me déposer j'ai pas mon
permis je n'avais pas votre permis de
conduire quel âge avez-vous je fais quoi
c'est une hybride
comment t'es arrivé là maintenant tu ne
vas certainement pas me piquer mon lit
je me demandais si vous pourriez nous
aider
c'est pas trop sympa comment ça a été il
a été super tu peux te féliciter
d'un chat
vous croyez pouvoir tout gérer tout seul
et ben non personne n'y arrive
je suis Peppa dites vous auriez une
pièce à me prêter qu'est-ce que vous
avez fait tu vas me rendre la petite
souris
[Musique]